alors on rit vers l'est en rebond soir
donc moi alors vous êtes ici pour nous
parler d'un livre consacré à votre père
par l'historien philippe delorme et qui
s'appelle l'homme qui rêvait d'être roi
donc c'est des entretiens avec le comte
de paris alors dans un pays où depuis
charles maurras et l'action française le
royalisme et assimilés à l'extrême
droite au nationalisme à l'antisémitisme
c'est un livre salutaire où l'on vérifie
que votre père était à des kilomètres en
fait du royalisme de charles maurras
était un démocrate un sensible aux idées
de justice sociale et anticolonialiste
voilà il y avait une incompatibilité
d'humeur entre morat c est mon père
ouais parce que maurras ou les je pense
diriger mon père et mon père avait des
idées très social il a écrit un livre
sur le prolétariat
oui oui puis même sur l' affaire dreyfus
il n'était pas d'accord avec maurras sur
le problème juif était pas d'accord avec
maurras son nationalisme n'était pas
d'accord avec maurras et finalement il
était presque à l'opposé de maurens
totalement en une rupture entre l'action
française et votre père qu'on appelait à
l'époque le prince rouge mais oui
ouais il avait beaucoup d'aversion pour
tous les régimes totalitaires ou disons
autoritaire des années 30
ce soit franco que ce soit mussolini que
ce soit salazar il avait il a failli
être mis en prison en espagne par franco
ouais mais parce que il aider les
français est repassé la frontière alors
été favorable à la création de l'état
d'israël et il a condamné les accords de
munich
tout à fait il est même venu en france
clandestinement pour faire une
conférence de presse près de paris il
pilotait son avion est arrivé avec son
avion il a fait ça avec conférence de
presse
il est reparti après alors pendant la
guerre on lui refuse de combattre sous
l'uniforme français puisqu'il était
exilé il rend des religions étrangères
pour se battre quand même pour la mecque
l'astronome orliac ce cas peu dommage
dans la cadre de votre père et surtout
pendant la guerre c'est que s'ils
étaient partis à londres en juin 40
peut-être que la france reid monarque
aujourd'hui alors de gaulle lui était
profondément monarchiste il été
influencé par les par les idées
monarchiste dans sa jeunesse
donc il a laissé entrevoir à votre père
la possibilité de lui succéder mais les
gaullistes qui entourait de gaulle l'ont
convaincu de se représenter c'est là que
votre père a fait son infarctus ça l'a
énormément sa touche et oui puisque en
fait toute sa vie il a mené pour pour un
idéal qui était de servir son pays est
d'arriver à une place qui imaginait
qu'il souhaitait et que le général de
gaulle eut à faciliter un certain moment
et puis tout d'un coup fca qu on le
laisse tomber et c'est là où il a eu son
infarctus il s'en est jamais relevé je
vais essayer deux ans avant de le mettre
en garde
alors ce que le bouquin ne raconte pas
c'est la fin de votre père qui est
beaucoup moins glorieuse dirais-je il
avait même dilapider la fortune d
orléans qui paraît mardi par exemple un
sou non je ne dirais pas que nous
n'avons plus un sou nous avons certaines
certaines choses
d'ailleurs la succession n'est pas de
terminer elle va se terminer
incessamment parce que j'ai décidé avec
tous mes frères et soeurs de refermer la
boîte de pandore et de ne prendre qu y
rester et nous allons donc nous
organiser dans ce sens là et puis la fin
terrible quand il dans cette petite
maison à chantilly avec madame friis
elle passe la serpillière il écoute la
valise rtl c'est dur ça non c'était
assez dur pour lui mais je crois qu'à
partir du moment où il ya eu son
infarctus qu'il a décidé de
il a décidé d'arrêter tout ils étaient
désenchantée de la vie ouais des
célèbres à quoi vous souvenez de son
père mais jouissent ai vu beaucoup de
photos de la valise rts à patrice
d'écouter la valise rtl quand on la
gagne